Marlene Berman is the George a and Helen
Dunham Cowan professor of cognitive
neuroscience in the Center for the
neural basis of cognition and the
department of psychology in 2015 she
became the first female scientist from
Carnegie Mellon inducted into the
National Academy of Sciences and tonight
she will be talking to us about
unraveling the neural code good evening
I'm honored to represent the CMU faculty
at this evening's event humans are
remarkably adept at recognizing tens of
thousands of faces irrespective of the
lighting condition the orientation of
the head even the sparsity of the input
and we can rapidly and mostly without
error recognize the faces captured in
the silk screens at the Andy Warhol
Museum in Pittsburgh the question I will
address is how is this accomplished by
the brain so effortlessly the field of
neuroscience has made tremendous
progress in the last couple of years
studying such questions for example we
now routinely place observers in an MRI
machine such as this one and we have a
fantastic 3 Tesla Siemens Vario magnet
at Carnegie Mellon and we project images
such as faces objects scenes into the
bore of the magnet and we track which
areas of the brain are responsive to
these kinds of visual stimuli we've
already been able to demarcate areas
associated with scenes the areas in
green areas associated with object
recognition this large swath of blue
with its size probably reflecting the
myriad of objects that have to be
represented in the cortex what I will do
today is talk to you about the red areas
these are the parts of the brain that
are select
of lead driven when we look at a face
but when we look at a face we don't
simply say this is a face rather than a
cut we recognize the face at an
individual level and the question is how
is that done the findings I will
describe to you today come from an
investigation in which we look under the
hood in these red areas and discover
what the neural code is that permits us
to individuate thousands of faces in
these experiments we put a subject into
the bore of the magnet and then we show
them faces many very similar homogeneous
faces it will not be that difficult to
derive a neural signature for very
different faces so for example the
neural code for my face and Steve
Chase's face are pretty different from
each other we want to test the system at
its upper bound and so we present 60
faces all very similar no distinguishing
characteristics and we record the neural
code that is activated for each of the
faces shown ear schematically is this 3
by 3 matrix with differential activation
patterns this allows us to characterize
the different codes associated with each
individual face but we go further than
this we ramp up the challenge if we
really understand the neural code then
we should be able to invert it and
reconstruct the image that was on the
screen that gave rise to the neural
activation in the first place it's a
little bit like having a dictionary
where you've got images of faces and a
neural code and if we really understood
that relationship we should take the
neural code and reconstruct the image
with
going into too much technical discussion
suffice it to say that we derive a
computational characterization of the
space of these neural activation
patterns and we are then able to take an
entirely new neural pattern which I've
depicted here as this green oval with a
question mark and drop it into this
computational model and derive its
weights along all of the dimensions add
them all together and produce a
reconstructed face here are some of the
results at the top of four examples of
the face stimuli and below are the
neural reconstructions
so the first exciting result is that we
were able to reconstruct faces rather
than random patterns
the second exciting result was that we
were able to reconstruct different faces
rather than a single homogeneous face in
response to all of the stimuli and last
we were able to show that the neural
reconstruction for each individual face
is more similar to the original stimulus
compared to any other stimulus in the
set suggesting that we have specificity
and statistical power precise
understanding of the neural code these
novel results
represent the state of the art in the
field and are the product of an
interdisciplinary collaboration at
Carnegie Mellon okay so we know what's
going on in these red areas one possible
application of these findings is at some
future point we might be able to insert
electrodes in the brains of say blind
individuals and transmit neural signals
directly into these areas that have the
neural codes essentially so convened
any of the obstacles like problems in
the eye problem in the relay from the
eye to the brain this is somewhat
futuristic but actually we thought that
developing brain computer interfaces
like Steve chases just told us was also
futuristic and it is here today although
not blind I'm going to show you one such
candidate population who might also
benefit from this application and these
are individuals who are what we will
call face blind are unable to recognize
individual faces the technical term is
congenital prosopagnosia I'll use CP as
an abbreviation somewhat like in the
story of oliver sexes of the men who
mistook his wife for a hat which is that
littles comedic depiction on the left
hand side shown faces of celebrities
like these on the right these
individuals are unable to recognize them
notwithstanding the fact that they know
an enormous amount about Marilyn Monroe
or Elvis Presley they are just unable to
individuate the face and know who it is
they don't have any overt neurological
problem and this may be somewhat similar
to developmental dyslexia in which kids
don't seem to master pattern recognition
of words these individuals don't seem to
master pattern recognition for faces
the disorder runs in families and it's
incidence is about 2% of the population
that these individuals cannot do this
face identification suggests that there
is something wrong with the neural code
that I've just described to you
in fact we've discovered what the
problem is in these individuals and it
turns out that the problem is not
actually in that neural code area it's a
problem because that area
is not receiving signals from the
distributed circuit from these other red
areas that are described to you earlier
so we showed this by using a novel
technology that allows us to map out the
circuit the fiber tracts the white
matter that connects up all of those red
areas that I showed you a little while
back this technique is called diffusion
tensor imaging and we can essentially
draw up the wiring diagram of this
distributed face network in contrast
with control individuals and here we
have data from six individual control
participants all of whom show very nice
fiber tracts colored in blue that
project to this neural code area we see
that in the congenital prosopagnosia the
tracts are either structurally
impoverished or interrupted perhaps you
can even see on the right hand side that
in the one hemisphere we were only able
to uncover a few threads of a fiber
tracked in one of these individuals
moreover the extent of the reduction in
this fasciculus in this fiber bundle is
correlated with the severity of the face
recognition deficit circumventing this
defunct circuit and projecting
transmitting the neural code directly
into this important region of cortex
might offer these congenitally face
blind individuals the opportunity to
recognize their sons daughters spouses
friends as I've shown in the course of
recognizing an individual face extensive
neural computation is involved and
disruptions can occur the research I've
presented has both a basic science and a
translational goal elucidating the under
lying neural code and developing a
comprehensive understanding of how
behavior is accomplished is one goal and
perhaps at some point being able to
develop applications to circumvent
sensory and perceptual impairments
represents the other goal namely the
translational or application side I'd
like to end off here by expressing my
deep gratitude to Carnegie Mellon
University for its support for the
faculty and for pushing us to strive for
excellence in all that we do thank you
you